robert laffont le président mitterrand
en voyage à la réunion pour 48 heures
c'est un voyage placé sous le signe de
l'égalité c'est à dire que nos
compatriotes du bout du monde doivent
être traités comme ceux de la métropole
d'autant que vous le savez sans doute
pas réunion est durement touchée par le
chômage
le chef de l'état n'est pas accompagné
du ministre des départements et
territoires d'outre-mer monsieur pons ni
accueilli sur place par michel debré
député de la réunion depuis 25 ans
bernard pons lui a expliqué qu'il
s'agissait selon lui d' un déplacement à
caractère électoral et qu'il n'avait
donc pas à être présent dès son arrivée
le président de la république a lancé un
appel à la justice
reportage de notre envoyé spécial rachid
arhab 35 degrés à l'ombre des ombrelles
ambiance créole pour accueillir le
président de la république sur l'île de
la réunion
ambiance créoles et slogans créole avec
les versions locales et multiple de
tonton tient bon sur le parking de
l'aéroport plusieurs milliers de
personnes et beaucoup de militants
communistes venus réclamer égalité
justice pour les habitants des
départements d'outre-mer
un appel entendu est amplifié par
conçoit mitterrand lui même je viens j'y
suis lancé un appel à la fraternité à
l'unité à l'égalité à la justice
on me dira ce sont des mots dont j'ai
dit qu'ils étaient employés depuis trop
longtemps pour que certains ne cessent
pas d'y croire et bien mesdames et
messieurs chers amis j'y crois que toute
menace
le voyage présidentiel a été boycottée
par les ministres du gouvernement
schirrhein le chef de l'état n'en semble
pas contrarier au contraire dit même
l'entourage de l'elysée
les petites piques politiques de ce
voyage ont commencé dès l'étape à la
mairie de saint-denis face au maire rpr
qui avait vanté le bilan du gouvernement
chirac et qui avait surtout regretté que
le président ne soit pas venue à la
réunion plus tôt françois mitterrand a
sorti le fleuret je suis venu si j'ai
bien compris ce que vous avez dit un peu
tardivement
cela vaut mieux que de ne pas venir du
tout comme cela est arrivé à d'autres
présidents de la république et vous
savez que mon voyage était prévu pour le
mois de novembre
par courtoisie chez jugé nécessaire de
ne pas multiplier les voyages depuis ce
officiel en l'espace de trois semaines
ce qui m'a conduit à reporter ce voyage
ou mois de février sans qu'aucune
confusion soit possible mais au
demeurant cela est très indifférent
allusion à peine voilée au dernier
voyage de jacques chirac ici un voyage
programmé presque en même temps que
celui du président qui avait préféré
alors attendre des jours meilleurs
et à voir l'accueil que françois
mitterrand a reçu ce matin la
tontonmania à gagner la réunion l'île où
est né un certain raymond pas au cours
de sa promenade dans la ville de saint
denis françois mitterrand est passé tout
près de la maison natale de raymond
barre c'est un peu l'image symbole de ce
voyage présidentiel organisé le jour
même où le candidat de l'udf se déclare
officiellement le hasard fait parfois
très bien les choses